in speaking to one another.
Lest your deeds become
invalidated while you don't
even realize it. So this verse
here, this second verse, of
Suratul Hajurat, there's a
reason or an incident that
occurred and Allah sent this
verse down. So, Abu Bakr and
Omar had a dispute
in the company of the prophet
and they started to argue and
as they argued as arguing
people usually do, they started
to raise their voices and Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala sent down,
oh you who have believed, do
not raise your voices above the
voice of the prophet. And so we
see here that the verse was
revealed and it wasn't it
wasn't with regards to them
speaking to him with raised
voice or yelling at him.
Rather, they were yelling at
each other in his in his
presence. And so, one thing we
understand is that, being in
the presence of the prophet is
unique and different than being
in the presence of any other
human being. That is that we do
not do anything that will
that might interpreted as a
disrespect of the prophet and
part of that is that a
gathering in which which
contains the prophet must be a
gathering of great honor and a
gathering of great etiquette
and part of that is that our
voices are at a reasonable
and respectable level. This is
one aspect of the verse.
Another aspect of the verse is
that is physically raising your
voice above the voice of the
prophet and we have other
aspects such as
metaphorically figuratively,
raising your voice above the
voice of the prophet meaning
that the prophet has a
narration, a statement about a
certain thing, a ruling on
something, or how this thing
should be understood, and I
dismiss that with my own
opinion. I dismiss that with my
own ideas And in doing so, I
have now set myself up as a
kind of peer to the prophet
just as a person who respects
another will not raise their
voice above that person.
Likewise, appear a peer will
speak to his peer with regular
talk and voice. Now, go take
any pains or go out of his way
in any way. Two, to pull out
any stops with regards to
particular etiquettes in
speaking to to to his peer and
so, my peer, someone who's
equal to me in status, he has
an idea and I have an idea. He
has a take on something and I
have a take on something and
that should never be the
relationship between the
prophet and his follower,
right? The relationship between
prophet and follower is I have
an idea. He has an idea my idea
is his idea, right? My take is
his take. I may be correct or
incorrect and the basis for
that and the scales of of right
and wrong with regards to that
is the words of the prophet
Those words, those takes, they
trump anything that I would
have to say. I am the follower.
He is the leader. He is the
master. He is the one who is
walking ahead of me. I'm
walking behind him. I don't
raise my voice over his voice.
I do not
contradict him as I would
someone who is my peer. This is
the relationship of a follower
to a prophet and it has to
remain in that way. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says as
well and do not speak to him as
and do not address him as you
address one another. We don't
raise our voice above the
prophet voice and speaking to
him or in speaking around him
that is physically and
figuratively and we do not
address him or speak to him
except as a follower, a humble
follower too, a a speaks to his
master and speaks to his
guidance, speaks to his leader.
And a part of that, there are
many aspects of this. This is a
general rule but a part of that
is speaking to the prophet is
not speaking to any other
human being. So, we cannot
refer to him if if the
companions didn't used to speak
to him and refer to him by his
first name. Say, you know, like
you would call out to your
friend. They would not call out
to him using his first name. He
had to call out to him saying,
messenger of Allah, prophet of
Allah, or by his the bare
minimum is the utmost of
respect, right? And there's a
difference between that and
speaking. There's a difference
between speaking to someone and
speaking about someone.
Speaking about someone is a
more general thing. Speaking to
someone is very specific. So,
what does that mean? So, if I'm
speaking to the prophet I will
not call to him, refer to him
by his first name. But if I'm
speaking about him and I refer
to him by his first name, well,
that might be perfectly okay.
Just when we make dua, we
make dua in Muhammad. Muhammad.
I'm not addressing him. I'm
speaking to Allah about him.
Speaking about somebody is
different than speaking to
somebody. It's a person
may call his father, will only
refer to his father as sir or
father or dad, what have you.
But you're asked, who's your
father? You say his name? So
and so is my father. Because
speaking about is different
than speaking to. So, in
speaking to the prophet there's
a certain level of respect that
must be observed as a bare
minimum. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says, lest your deeds
become invalidated whilst you
are unaware. What is meant by
invalidating deeds here. It
doesn't mean that your religion
will be invalidated. Usually,
invalidation of deeds in the
Quran happens with happens with
disbelief. However, not always
and this is an example of that.
Because disbelief is a choice.
It's not a mistake that you
make. Right? So then point
here. Disbelief is a choice not
an accident. Just Islam is
a choice. The Islam that's
going to that's going to
benefit you and I in the
hereafter is a choice. It's not
an accident. You don't
accidentally become Muslim.
There's no such thing. You have
to choose to become Muslim and
make the conscious choice to be
Muslim. Likewise, in order to,
then depart from Islam, to
leave Islam. You have to make
the conscious decision to do
so. It's not an accidental
thing. So, the statement of
Allah, lest you, lest your
deeds become, lest your needs
become invalidated lest your
deeds become voided whilst you
don't even know This means that
this sin is big enough to void
other good deeds that a person
does, not by way of but by way
of, there are some bad deeds
that a person can do that will
affect their good deeds, right?
And so, in this same meaning,
prophet said for instance, in
Sahih Al Bukhari who said, he
said, whoever misses
then their deeds have become
invalidated, right? That
doesn't mean that a person
becomes a disbeliever. It means
that their deeds have been
invalidated by this major,
major disobedience and this is
the same thing here. So,
there's no such thing as a
person accidentally becoming a
disbeliever. Yes, accidentally
doing something of disbelief?
Yes. That's something that can
happen. But accidentally
leaving Islam no. Leaving Islam
in the sense that you will be
brought you you will be put in
hell for eternity. Leaving
Islam in the sense that you are
no longer Muslim. In the side
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
This is a choice. This is not
an accidental ordeal. And like
wise becoming Muslim. This is a
conscious decision that a
person makes. It's not an
accidental thing that a person
becomes a Muslim.